can you back this up for us please sure
i understand you knew the deceased yeah
we were we didn't know him at all met
him this morning never even got his real
name he just wanted us to call him pops
so there's nothing you can tell me about
him where he lived where his families
are no he just said i'm pops and those
were the last words he ever spoke well
i'll be back to take your info down case
there are more questions happy to be of
service take care of pops for us
what was that
i took silas's wallet before they got
here so he has no id on him he's
officially an unknown so now he can be
buried like he wanted
okay but what about his pills
didn't the bottle in his pocket have his
name on it
oh [ __ ]
i'll go grab him you create a
distraction create a distraction you'll
be great
[Music]
hello
hey
i just remembered some more stuff about
pops yeah
yeah
he said he was born in
tennessee did he say where in tennessee
he did i can't remember where
maybe you could name some places in
tennessee jog my memory
nashville
well what not like that memphis oh don't
be silly
um
he named some street address street
addresses in tennessee yeah it was a
weird number something i never thought
could be a house
hey that junk is stealing drugs from a
corpse no i wasn't that's not what was
happening i wasn't stealing drugs
i was just
i just wanted to touch this dead man's
dick
no lure against that
there definitely is right yeah
so um i was stealing drugs but i'll just
put them back right now
there they are
back
no
come back here
[Applause]
[Music]
jillian g
hey
what are you doing here i brought your
house back
plus someone to see how much trouble
you're in it's only a misdemeanor since
silas can't press charges it's actually
a good loophole stealing from a corpse
you mean grey rubbing
i guess i do mean grave robbing grave
robbing is a life hack yeah well anyway
you were right
i obviously can't do this alone and
since you're without a partner now
i came to see if you
still interested in teaming up
really
i thought i was the most stressful
person you've ever met well before i saw
trudeau for silas
that was pretty
cool thank you
you know i didn't actually touch his
dick
i meant about the pills
you know him for like 12 hours
he was kind of an [ __ ]
and you're still willing to go to jail
just to help him out
i just wanted him to get buried so his
life meant something
i guess he's still not gonna get that
tombstone
[Music]
you